What if I wasn't here, but instead I was there
-- floating right in front of you?
Holographics bro.
They're coming.
Greetings programs, Trace here for DNews -- Yes,
I'm really here, I am not a hologram...yet.
There may soon be a day where I'll just pop
into your livingroom, into the palm of your
hand or I'll walk alongside you down the street.
The idea behind holographic technology has
been around since the late 1940s when British
scientist Dennis Gabor coined the word hologram
-- from the Greek words meaning whole message
-- but those are a little different... we've
got these laser-based holograms on everything
from novelty toys, credit cards and money.
Since those post-War years, holograms have
jumped out of their little two-dimensional
windows into three dimensional space!
The most famous one recently was probably
from last year's Coachella -- where a holo-Tupac
made an appearance.
But the most widespread recognition of holographic
technology is on Star Trek with the Holodeck
-- a place where anyone can put themselves
anywhere thanks to 3D, touchable holograms.
We're not quite there yet, though people in
the business of holograms DO think we'll see
a holodeck someday.
But so far, all holographic technology is
really just visual trickery.
The Coachella-Tupac wasn't floating in 3D
space, but projected onto an angled see-through
mylar screen, a technique that's been used
since Victorian times with mirrors and glass.
It's essentially the same thing you'd see
at Disney's Haunted Mansion, if less shiny-happy.
Holograms work because our eyes are tricked
into seeing something closer to us than it
is.
Using a concave mirror, the "hologram" appears
to separate from the projector, but it's an
optical illusion.
Similar to 3-D television and movies, if you
only had one eye and you didn't use both,
it wouldn't be floating anywhere.
Another holographic problem is the brain's
tendency to see problems in the world around
us.
The Uncanny Valley is something we've talked
a bit about on DNews.
If a hologram looks real, but isn't done quite
right the brain doesn't process it properly,
and we become uncomfortable, afraid or sometimes
even sick.
We know something's wrong, but our primitive
cerebrum can't comprehend it and experience
this fear response.
We've also yet to figure out how to get rid
of something to project ONTO.
I've seen "holographics" try using smoke,
water, see-through screens, mannequins and
animatronics.
But they're basically movies on a different
type of screen.
While someday we'll be able to project ourselves
out of a droid; we're still in the dark on
that one.
And we still can't touch it, that's a whole
other thing.
What do you think?
Are holographics worth it?
Thanks for watching DNews today!
Holo-atcha boy!
Come find us on Twitter, Facebook and Google
Plus to see behind the scenes stuff, suggest
stories or just chat with us.
Me, Anthony and Laci are around, why aren't
you?
Thanks for tuning in guys, see you next time.